[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle sauvage qu'est mal
je suis propriétaire des formes bord du
lac du visage geste est le thème du vin
y avait ces personnes qui formaient le
terre industrielle ici c'est s'informent
co prêter c'est sa femme pour le tout
les community d'un mariage je n'ai
appris auprès de sea france pour simple
qui permet ainsi chaque personne j'avais
une petite parcelle des doigts qu'avec
les terres agricoles représentent 2 % du
territoire québécois qui si on regarde
le nombre de fermes le monde de faire me
en baisse de 2% depuis cinq ans vous
êtes un peu à contre courant parce que
vous même vous n'êtes pas agriculteur
nouveau cd quand même ses terres quelle
importance vous accordez à l'agriculture
aux grimpeurs m elle capte en aide
cedar mois soit aussi et en coopératif
c'est un bon pour tout le monde il c'est
bon pour l'économie
pour les îles bizarre aussi dans cette
forme j'ai vicieux beaucoup d'étudiants
or tout le monde en france etats unis
les autres sections du canada aussi 2006
reste d'oublier t il dire que vous êtes
un homme d'affaires mais avec la ferme
si vous faites pas de profit non non on
fait la mission civile et d'autres
hélicoptères et de ciel qui appelait
mois par le recteur indiciels ici c'est
non non j'ai pas être resté devant des
pommes ce terrain